[Music]
what is the features of selenium ID as a
recordin play it will locate you know
elements automatically using locators
like ID name link XPath CSS we'll be
talking about locators in detail then we
will get into the selenium webdriver
drop-down selection of selenium commands
feature so you can debug your test cases
you have the capability to save your
tests in HTML if you want to save your
test scripts what you have created or
what has been recorded you can save them
into HTML as well as you can convert
them into webdriver as well support for
selenium user extension dot J's file we
will see that scheduler for scheduling
your tests you can schedule your test
case as well let's open Firefox and you
can see I have also Firefox 55 and I
have selenium ID also installed so as
you all know that the official website
of City MIT it is selenium h2 download
you may go to this side and if you go to
the side if you go down here you will
find download latest release version
from this link when you click on this
link so this is the selenium ID and here
is the download link when you click on
this link it will always see
so it says download all battles ignore
it
let me open it in Firefox itself the
same link when you click on this link
you will see here this add-on is not
compatible with your version of Firefox
ok so it may say that either you say
download anyway or you can downgrade
your selenium
I'm sorry Firefox version and can down
then download it there are two ways to
do that second when you download it you
will get this - or this plug-in here in
Tools menu so the Guru tools here you
will find selenium IDE you may see an
icon as well of this lynnium ID for
right at this place there so here at my
place at my end it is not showing as I
have other plugins installed but it may
be possible that you don't have multiple
plugins so you may find this shortcut of
selenium ID right at this place as well
okay now let's open selenium ID and
let's see how it looks like so this is
how it looks like so this is the ID tool
which you will get where this is the
button which is by default but in the
recorded mode just by default in the
recorded mode and now if you open or do
anything in Firefox browser it will
record that and well log all these steps
what you will follow
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here